prince george is officially england's
cutest little fan
the seven-year-old royal who celebrates
his eighth birthday later this month
had a big weekend out with his parents
prince william and kate middleton
cheering on england in the euro finals
at wembley stadium
in london on sunday
[Music]
that's george rocking a matching suit
with his dad
but don't let the fancy getup fool you
george totally let loose at the game
and get ready to cue the oz
because cameras caught the sweet moment
england scored a goal
and the father-son duo jumped up out of
their seats
and hugged each other
william threw his fist in the air
clapped and cheered as george hugged his
mom before throwing his head back
and letting out a big laugh with his dad
of course england ended up losing to
italy and as the game came to a close
the duke of cambridge was seen
comforting george
but this is hardly george's first sports
outing with his dad
last month william celebrated father's
day by helping kick off a half marathon
in norfolk england
prince george and his six-year-old
sister princess charlotte
attended the event with their dad and
were right by his side to count down to
the start of the race
[Applause]
but back to that soccer match william
personally tweeted following the big
game writing quote
heartbreaking congratulations azuri on a
great victory
england you've all come so far but sadly
this time
it wasn't our day you can all hold your
heads high and be so proud of yourselves
i know there's more to come and on
monday
williams spoke out again condemning
comments against the england players
following the team's loss
tweeting quote i am sickened by the
racist abuse aimed at
england players after last night's match
it is totally unacceptable that players
have to endure this abhorrent behavior
it must stop now and all those involved
should be held accountable
as for kate her appearance at the game
came after it was announced that she
would have to sit out her royal duties
for a few days to self-isolate following
an exposure to coven 19.
so her husband hosted a tea event solo
honoring national health service staff
and frontline workers
of course all this comes after william's
highly anticipated reunion with his
brother harry
the two reunited earlier this month for
the unveiling of the princess diana
statue
in honor of what would have been their
late mother's 60th birthday
the reunion was a big deal as it came
amid reports that the two brothers are
at odds
following harry's decision to step back
from his senior royal duties in 2020
and his explosive tell-all interview
with oprah winfrey earlier this year
there's clearly still a lot of hurt a
lot of resentment and a degree
of mistrust i think on both parts but i
think the hope is that
come july when we are hoping to see the
brothers stand
once again shoulder by shoulders that
the relationship will be
stronger and in a better place the
statue unveiling marked the first time
the brothers had
publicly come face to face since april
when they attended the funeral of their
grandfather prince philip
diana always said to them always stay
close
don't ever fall out you'll be devastated
that that is what's happened
and she would be wanting them to feed
her together for that unveiling of the
statue in her honor